tom is your arm doing better yeah i mean
you know
oh that's right you weren't
it was the right they're good so the
nerves you almost died yeah the nerve
is bruised it's not damaged so it'll
come back
but like you know i can grip yeah but
they're called your extenders yeah and i
can't extend this handle
i don't know do you do you does it still
um because i know nerve pain and nerve
issues is probably one of the most
annoying [ __ ] to deal with
numb so like this is all numb yeah
right here i don't have like shooting
nerve pain or anything oh thank god
uh but like it's annoying because you
just go like you wanna go
yeah grab something and i can't like i
literally can't
you know i i one of my weird anxiety
things things that i
i can throw me into a full panic because
because i used to have breast implants
and they were double d's and i took them
out
you had double d double they were nice
you hated them
i mean wait you had them when you were
together um yeah yeah
when she i i met her and she didn't have
them and then he begged me not to get
them he's like i like little kiwi
titties like please don't get them right
and then she got him anyway because she
didn't really know me that well really
like it was early on yeah i was like
well you know i don't know how
how long this guy is gonna stick around
like i'm gonna need these titties to
parlay you know some kind of success in
my life
right and then um might have took them
out because i i just hated them i hated
the way i felt in them but
it caused a lot of like nerve damage in
like the center of my chest so i don't
have sensation here
so when i touch that area and i don't
feel anything it it likes i spiral into
a panic because i'm like
but that skin and how come i can't like
i don't like not having sensation
yeah i mean yeah it's it is a it's a
weird it's a weird sensation the the
hand thing because the knee
like you know i'm i can walk and go
upstairs and downstairs now because i
tore this
tendon you know completely that one that
as crazy as it is it's like easy fix
your cyborg and that's good right you
just know like i know it's not
stable yet because it takes it's gonna
take like a full year
to get the quads back to where they were
but the hand thing like the arm you know
i have a huge
i have titanium plates in my arm so so
like
that part i'm not even that's fine
like i can you know i can pick things up
i can move like
but i can't ex like the nerve makes it
so that i
can't extend my hand yeah can't do it i
have a question
i have a question yeah i don't even know
what happened
for real yeah i i knew
i saw you know i mean yeah well i didn't
see this
oh my bobby you've never seen this
you've never seen this bobby
let's look at his arm oh my [ __ ] god
dude he's never
oh my [ __ ] god see this
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
he knew you broke something but he
didn't see the video no i saw annie
letterman's
one where she was playing basketball and
she did a thing and i didn't know why
that was the thing yeah no i've never
seen let me say something right now
i swear to god i'm my mother's life yeah
i've never seen that i believe you
yeah i believe you why did you do that
there's a freak accident man oh my god
it really doesn't it was yeah it's rough
oh my god
can you watch that of yourself i've seen
it so many times now you know
like uh yeah that's why my nerves are
[ __ ]
you're actually dealing with the pain
really well yeah well i'm the one that
said call 9-1-1 because they're all
looking at me and they're oh you're all
right
i was like call 9-1-1
but you you lost weight from it almost
30 pounds yeah so that's a good thing
good
because you look completely different
from the from there yeah yeah and i had
just
beat bert that's what nobody talks about
i just beat him and
that was after we competed so we
competed we were doing
fat guy dunk contest which is like was
bert there yeah burt's the one who takes
my arm and puts it down
oh my god so we we competed and we're
going
you know we lower the rim to like seven
feet and then we go seven and a half
and then eight and then eight and a half
and then on nine
he couldn't do it i did it so they're
like it's over you win
and so i was like great and somebody
there was like you know tom you got hops
man like you should try to go
i swear to god though you should try i
think you can do a little bit higher
and they crank it up three inches oh my
god right because it's a it's a crank
thing it goes to nine foot three
that black dude roy is a basketball
coach he pulled me aside i told the
story on that thing but he goes
i'm gonna need you to dig deep on this
one
i told this because it's true when he
said it you know he
like i i get like a flashback to like
coaches like when i
played sports you know so i was like
like i was like i am going to dig deep
right now
and like and i feel the adrenaline like
your throat kind of dries out
you're like i'm going to give this
everything i [ __ ] have
and as i when i what what happens like
what you're seeing there is i'm when i
push off
my left leg i tear my patellar tendon
in half like it rips off the bone
and so it's it's a it's like it's a
freak accident yeah
that's just the perfect and then my body
not consciously
instinctively right there so that right
when i go in the air like when i'm
leaving right like i'm pushing off right
there my tendon's already
poured oh my god it's torn
and then instinctively my arm i'm not
thinking about it my arm goes behind to
like
an asian guy because i don't know i
don't know if i'm
one or twenty inches off the ground you
know what's happening so fast you're
like
so your arm goes behind your back and
then i land on it and it just
splits in half oh you're playing yeah oh
my god
that's 245 pounds too oh
oh my god yeah wow
oh my god so yeah
that happened so that's why my [ __ ]
hand doesn't work that's why i haven't
seen you in a while
yeah well well tom's been everywhere
since that accident
he hasn't been home no but i was i was
in the hospital and in rehab for three
weeks
so i spent i spent december in
in a hospital and then in a rehab
facility i remember thinking before
before this video came out oh you got
covered from the hospital
hospital yeah oh [ __ ] while you were
there you got covered i got
covered in the hospital yeah oh lord oh
imagine that i don't have all that and
then the cove yeah
i remember i thought i had oxy
withdrawals because i was taking so much
oxy at first
they were just pumping of course are you
on the pump and i'm like
no they were bringing me the pills and
they were giving me dilaudid
straighten the iv and then straighten my
arm but you didn't have they didn't let
you pump it on your own
no no but they were coming on a pretty
regular rotation
you'll go though the lot it's hard to
dilated yes the oxis i was like
okay i guess i feel a little better like
it was never enough
you know when they were like how's your
pain now i'm like yeah still everything
still hurts
really yeah and they're like how about
now i'm like 100 percent
dilaudid you could thought it was like
felt like what
heroin must feel like because you'd feel
a warm
rush through your chest and then you'd
just be like
oh you know and then like and then
they're like hey now i'm like i feel
pretty good now
like just good night move yeah yeah and
i would ask for it
like i guess i'm more dilaudid and then
you're like
yeah yeah yeah but yeah um um
i remember when you first tweeted that
you had broken like multiple
drones i was trying to sort out what had
happened the first thing was like oh
it's got to be a car accident everyone
saw
the car and second i was like oh it must
have been an e-scooter because a lot of
my friends with like these
these new scooters are just [ __ ] i
know a couple people that ate [ __ ] on
them like
hard too like multiple fractures i know
somebody went to the hospital yeah yeah
yeah
but here's the question i wanted to ask
you is this normal that when something
happens to someone
that like my it's a it's like a fun
guessing game for me
like i have to know and i look through
80 000 comments
everyone's like oh like for instance
when someone dies condolences
condolences condolences that's
i go through everything what happened
like i do the same thing i do the same
thing
i do the same thing especially on a
death when they're like especially when
the person is
not of an age where you expect them to
die like eric myers
like eric myers and you go and you see
like eric myers passed away and you're
like what happened i still don't know
what happened
what i got was